a tentative deal between the A's in Las
Vegas has been announced but the
legislation still is not introduced
Governor Joe Lombardo State lawmakers
the A's and Clark County releasing a
joint statement saying they have an
agreement this morning the stadium would
be a 1.5 billion dollar situation state
senator Scott Hammond telling us the
bill won't be tied to a specific site he
also said the state's portion will be
180 million with Clark County putting up
another 120 million dollar Bond he
doesn't expect the actual bill to be
introduced until this weekend now you
can find all of our reporting on the A's
on our website over at 8newsnow.com